[Musik]
schweizer in los angeles für präsentiert
es ist ok wo sie sind
[Musik]
ja
abu dhabi
[Musik]
da sei
das leben für einen architekten in l e
er ist ein einziger hindernislauf vor
den täglichen scherer reingeht rossi in
seinem lieblingscafé e-mails
kontrollieren wenn ich unterwegs bin
e mails windhose in acht beantworten und
erledigen und so den wenn man die grafik
fertiges im mini e mails erledigt und
dann kann ich sie mit street view am
lenkrad seines rollenden zwei büros
flitz der richtung malibu wo er
versuchen wird die schwierige situation
eines kunden pass zu entwirren dass sich
mit administrativen kram umschlägt vier
jahre hat es gebraucht um eine
baubewilligung zu bekommen jetzt kann
sie endlich sein schweizer know how
unter beweis stellen oder merkt
amerikaner ganz anders ticken
europäische ist ja schon eigentlich noch
nicht so verbreitet sehr spitz
kalifornien stark einseitig und alles
ist das ganze schöne fahrt expectations
von mirko schweizerisch ist anders
expectations vom amerikaner und dafür
stellen wir uns einfach gegen sebastian
thrun funktioniert das nicht immer da
dass die schweiz ihre künstliche macht
sie nicht sagt ich gemacht bisschen
kritik ist gemacht bisschen kritik und
das ist eigentlich steuern in amerika
schon ich könnte so naja das ist ein tag
ist der über euro und hatte eigentlich
jetzt mal böse seid die immobilienkrise
eine fußstütze synchro und hatten auch
einen verkauft und hans renoviert und
vermietet und dann haben wir gemerkt
auch der service und das zeugs einer der
herren vorteil bei mir
das ist nur entscheidend sei dass man
ein stück land kaufen und jetzt einmal
das hoffest ruf stellen fast hätten sie
bei den waldbränden alles verloren
alles war hinein und vorne stark nach
links und rechts
das geht
[Musik]
unglaublich wie grüne es schon ist
wir fahren nach keinen tarif um die
ruinen der brände vom november zu sehen
man riecht es noch das feuer riess usa
ist es dunkel braun
es ist entscheidend ob sich die winkel
nach links oder nach rechts bewegen
entweder wetter wind in deine richtung
oder nicht ist es total willkürlich das
ist echt heran
hier kommen ein paar kräftige worden
canon 45 minuten von der stadt entfernt
eine filmstadt vom feuer zerstört das
waren alles alte film fließen diese
kirche wurde glaube ich für die tv-serie
westfeld verwendet und danach wurde auch
der rest dieses anwesen für west wald
genutzt
ich glaube die ersten brände habe ich
2005 gesehen
damals brannte griffith park man sah die
flammen von zu hause aus vor allem aber
den raum
diese enormen rauch massen die auf die
stadt zukommen
ich frage mich wie man das darstellen
die panik die um sich greift wo man
nichts tun kann und auch all diese
verlassenen städtischen gebiete all die
abgebrannten orte wo sich natur und
architektur vermischen eisenteile in
baumstämme zusammenwachsen
man kann sie nicht mehr voneinander
unterscheiden ich versuche so viel
material wie möglich zusammenzubekommen
so viele fotos wie möglich zum ich gehe
herum und fotografiere nach ereignissen
wie zum beispiel einem brand gehe ich
also an diese abgebrannten orte zurück
das ist wie verbrannte erde verteilt und
nasses spitze
aus der asche wiedergeboren werden hier
ergibt das sinn
tausende hektar land zerstört hunderte
von toten in los angeles mutieren träume
schnell zu alpträumen feuer dürre
erdbeben das leben führt einen teuren
kampf gegen den tod
doch die stadt gewinnt letztlich doch
immer die oberhand zurück das ist eben
los angeles
florian raz die zeit schon nach wenigen
wochen stehen die ersten prüfungen an
ich muss unbedingt lernen die
sogenannten midterms stehen haben das
ist nichts anderes als eine prüfung die
mitte des jahres stattfindet und 40
prozent der note ausmacht man muss also
etwas weniger lernen weil es ja nur fünf
wochen arbeit sind aber trotzdem toll
finde ich hier dass die bibliothek 24
stunden durchgehend geöffnet hat so ist
man flexibel
ich weiß dass ich mich in der nacht viel
besser konzentrieren kann
am morgen lernen ist wirklich nicht mein
ding wenn ich bis um vier in der früh in
der bibliothek lernen und am nächsten
tag bis um 14 uhr schlafen will weil ich
in der nacht so lange gelernt habe kann
ich das tun
ich kann das selbst entscheiden ein
echter pluspunkt für mich es geht dieses
kalt und ich habe den ganzen januar für
meine prüfungen gelernt ich hatte auch
keine ferien
das ist doch fast gefühl wie machst du
dort hast
nein ich muss
[Musik]
ich versuche immer meine mutter zu
beruhigen wenn nicht plötzlich etwas
stressen sollte werde ich jemand anderen
als meine mutter anrufen um sie nicht zu
beunruhigen
[Musik]
dora bereitet die rückkehr in die
schweiz fuhr ihre bilder nimmt sie nicht
mit die märkte sind original dies in
form in großvaters innere galerie er hat
da nicht von erste galerie der stadt
eröffnet cent lange lange zeit hat in
großvater den zielen kann die galerie
führt und die bilder habe ich alte blech
gibt wo mein vater gestorben ist
aber ich bin mit einem bild ruft wachse
die sind so ewig lange die familie nach
rechts weg nach mallorca und nachher
noch das anders und es ist einfach zeit
mit weniger hoch
[Musik]
mit wenig auszukommen das kennt randy
gut jede katze hat ihre persönlichkeit
ich kann mich gut mit roger
identifizieren weil er groß und
freundlich ist
er ist immer der erste der mich begrüßt
wenn ich sie füttere und die anderen
kommen dann hinterher
ich selber bin kein mitläufer ich bin
immer meinen eigenen weg gegangen
ich tue was ich für richtig halte ich
habe bewusst nie eine familie gegründet
dafür haben wir die tiere immer
geborgenheit gegeben sie helfen mir mich
zu entsprechen
man könnte sagen sie sind meine kinder
vor einem jahr habe ich mir ein haus in
der wüste gekauft diesen wohnwagen
benutze ich wenn ich in los angeles
arbeite und nicht nach hause fahren will
weil mein haus fast zwei autostunden
entfernt ist weil ich während neun
jahren in diesem gebäude gewohnt habe
geben meine ehemaligen nachbarn auf
meinem wohnwagen 8 und sie kümmern sich
um die katzen wenn ich nicht da bin
[Musik]
hallo emily wir sind da und haben die
bilder dabei wir nehmen sie ihn
einlassen
doris kollegin emily war sofort an den
bildern interessiert europäische malerei
gilt bei amerikanern als sicherer wert
ich stelle es hier hin weil ich denke
dass hier oben der beste platz ist jetzt
meine bilder hier sind muss ich hier
einziehen
wir haben ein freies zimmer die kinder
sind weg kannst du gut bilder aufhängen
wir stellen es zuerst auf den kaminsims
dann kannst du es hochheben dann siehst
du wo es sein muss
es ist gerade oder es ist ein abschied
ja ich liebe diese bilder vor allem
dieses hier
wir werden gut auf sie achten keine
sorge ich werde dir fotos schicken
es ist gut zu sehen dass sie einen
wirklich schönen platz bekommen haben
wir lieben diese bilder und diese bucht
ist einfach großartig
das ist mein lieblingsbild und das von
wir werden sie immer in ehren halten und
sie an unsere kinder weitergeben
das bedeutet mir sehr viel du kannst du
jederzeit besuchen
sie waren etwa 100 jahren besetzter
verlieren
geschafft so habe ich sie immer dass
tusch
[Musik]
hier wird nicht zwangsläufig innerhalb
der familie vererbt man kann auch unter
freunden vererben meinen wohnwagen ist
ein geschenk eines kunden der letztes
jahr verstorben ist hat ihn für sich
selbst gekauft und als er ihn
schließlich nicht mehr brauchte hatte
ihn mir geschenkt er war schauspieler
und hat im film full metal jacket den
marines rasen gespielt
er sagte zu mir nehmen das wohnmobil und
liebe dein abenteuer wenn ich irgendwo
hingehe muss ich nur essen und eiswürfel
kaufen
ansonsten habe ich praktisch alles es
ist wichtig immer einen sonnenschirm
dabei zu haben
die habe ich flossen und das hier ist
ein schwimmbrett ein golfschläger dann
einen mikrowellenherd und das ist der
kühlschrank der leer ist weil sie nicht
benutzen den kochherd habe ich noch
nicht benutzt weil ich noch nie richtig
gekocht habe jede katze hat ihre
vorliegen genau wie wir menschen
ich esse beispielsweise kein fleisch ich
bin vegetarier aber nicht 100% veganer
weil ich als schweizer immer noch gerne
ab und zu käse esse ich lebe seit zehn
jahren so und fühle mich heute viel
besser
[Musik]
florian milli stadt erobern endlich
taucht sie aus ihrer bücher welt auf wir
sind auf dem weg ins stadtzentrum nach
downtown los angeles
wir werden uns das künstlerviertel
ansehen den orks district es ist schön
die sonne scheint und es macht spaß die
stadt bei solchem wetter zu besichtigen
allerdings ist es schon eine autostadt
man hört dass ja die ganze zeit aber
wenn man hier ankommt hat man wirklich
auch sofort diesen eindruck man sieht
hier selten menschen zu fuß unterwegs
außer sie gehen mit ihrem hund gassi was
er tun müssen
ansonsten nimmt man das auto da mehr der
umweltschutz wichtig ist ist das schon
gewöhnungsbedürftig
[Musik]
45 minuten von hollywood entfernt locken
die reize des ozeans in san pedro
überall lachten oder boot so weit das
auge reicht um den unzähligen
alltäglichen herausforderungen zu
entkommen stieg sie gerne hätten sie
alles und dann an die sage schick
gemacht dann wollen se und ganze
mittelmeer und dann wieder überflügelt
haben ja auch vor der regatta segler und
verschiedene projekte ist einen guten
ausgleich zum alltag lebendig diese
kritik ist schön
das hilft das ganze ganze stress
abzubauen
dass am ende wieder frisch bis alles
wieder von vorn 3
[Musik]
in l -e ist sport religion glaubenssache
und halt sport hat hier weit mehr
anhänger als die kirchen
für einen langen aufstieg braucht man
bequeme schuhe wasser wir brauchen viel
wasser weil es ein ganz schönes stück
weges die schlüssel natürlich mit
schweizer kreuz auf dem schlüsselband
bis gleich alles in ordnung wenn sie
mich zur tür begleiten könnten zu diesem
haus
[Musik]
brandy besteigt seine stattlichen
pferdestärken und macht sich auf in die
berge
[Musik]
wer in die berge geht muss man sich vor
klapperschlangen und pumas in acht
nehmen wenn du auf die hügel gehst
sollst du dich vor wilden tieren in acht
nehmen
unter den hungrigen augen der coyoten
schlangen und pumas erklimmt randy mit
strammem schritt die steilen pfaden der
hollywood hills das da drüben das ist
der künstliche see
er heißt lake hollywood und ist ein
künstlicher trinkwasser stausee los
angeles ist eine schöne stadt
und wenn man jung ist hat sie einem viel
zu bieten
deshalb sollte man so früh wie möglich
hierher kommen somit 18 19 oder 20
jahren
ich war 25 jahre alt als ich herkam
ich wäre gerne früher gekommen aber ich
hatte damals seine arbeit und seine
freunde
deshalb habe ich etwas länger gewartet
wenn man älter wird wenn man in rente
geht gehen viele leute zurück in die
schweiz
da ist es viel ruhiger das leben in der
schweiz ist entspannter los angeles ist
das genaue gegenteil ja ist es los los
los mach mach mach darum empfehle ich
jungen leuten nicht zu zögern und gleich
hierher zu kommen
dafür muss man halt sein zuhause
zurücklassen was nicht einfach ist
ich habe auch meine arbeit meine familie
und meine freunde verlassen
aber es ist mein leben und ich wollte
dieses abenteuer leben
ich würde mich heute wieder so
entscheiden
[Musik]
florian erkundet derweil einen anderen
dschungel die street art wie ein museum
unter freiem himmel
das nirvana für jede bild jägerin jedes
jahr kommen hunderte künstler nach l wie
früher die goldwäscher jagen sie alle
dem großen traum hinterher und nur
einige unter ihnen erlangen berühmtheit
und bleiben so der ewigkeit erhalten
sowie francescas schwiegervater
fotos mir leid ich wollte nicht in eurem
bild sein
mach dir auch filmaufnahmen
wir drehen einen dokumentarfilm fürs
schweizer fernsehen für schweizer
fernsehen ich bin selber auch schweizer
was für ein zufall
auschwitz und ich habe einen
amerikanischen pass
ich arbeite als koch weist du schweizer
köche sind überall bekannt wir sind die
besten
das ist das erste mal das ich hier einem
schweizer über den weg laufen
das geht mir auch so verrückt schönen
tag noch
[Musik]
ursprünglich hieß los angeles das dorf
der königin der engel
wer ist heute die kleine königin der
enkel
[Musik]
da drüben sind und da sind die disney
studios
wir sind also mitten im zentrum der
film- und fernsehindustrie der bürger
airport wo mein wohnwagen steht ist noch
etwas weiter weg ich wohne neben dem
flughafen wahrzeichen haben manchmal
eine seltsame entstehungsgeschichte die
buchstaben des hollywood schriftzugs
wurden 1923 errichtet um für das
immobilienprojekt hollywood land zu
werben
25 jahre später ließ die handelskammer
den schrift talent entfernen
so entstand daraus das sinnbild des
hollywood kinos
wir sind da beim hollywood zeichen dem
bekannten schriftzug weil es so viele
vandalenakte gab ist der schriftzug nun
mit absperrungen geschützt und man
gelangt nicht mehr bis ganz zu den
buchstaben
ansonsten zahlt man 1000 dollar bußgeld
[Musik]
francesca bereitet ihre ausstellung für
die galerien zu kurz vor die ihre werke
zum thema feuer und brände zeigen wird
an ihrer seite maya ihre ohne bauliche
assistentin versuche es mal mit diesen
roten ich glaube ich werde solche rot
töne verwenden so was in der art
zuerst gebe ich ihr etwas zu tun dann
arbeite ich an etwas anderem weiter ich
werde schauen ob ich eine meiner kleinen
probearbeiten vervielfältigen und danach
aus schneide bilder machen kann
viele leute haben mir gesagt es sei eine
schweizer tradition scherenschnitte zu
machen
ich habe hier damit begonnen
scherenschnitte anzufertigen
ich habe ein wolken tagebuch angelegt
das ist ähnlich wie beim rauch die
formen ähneln sich davor habe ich sie
schon lange bewundert
da wir ja seit langem zusammenarbeiten
tauschen wir gedanken und ideen aus
manchmal müssen wir sie etwas
konkretisieren weil die ideen nur so
sprudeln und sie immer so viele einfälle
und pläne für die zukunft hat dass ich
manchmal mühe habe zu folgen
schau dir die wolken an sie sehen aus
wie rauch
[Musik]
das ist noch kein ausziehen sondern an
umräumen der hausverkauf hat aus seinem
preis können wir das hier vielleicht
etwas schräg stellen
diese kabel müssen hier weg ja sie
werden fotos machen dass ich nur für
station machen
in den vereinigten staaten werden häuser
umgestylt um die verkaufschancen zu
steigern
das home staging empfiehlt auch eine
verschönerung der deko die geschmäcker
sind verschieden
[Musik]
die geht kannst du mir dieser große
molkereien oder brauchst du sie gerade
die brender bezeichne ich als spektakel
sie stehen für zerstörung aber auch für
neuanfang
sie sind nicht nur negativ zumindest
versuche ich das so zu sehen
ein konfitüre glas mit wasser
ich werde einen lounge machen und sobald
es trocken ist werde ich einen teil dazu
verwenden die rauchschwaden darzustellen
die aus den wolken hervor gehen
das hier ist mein maler kittel
ich kann so viele flecken drauf machen
wie ich will gut wie die tropfen so
entstehen auch die firmen recht spontan
auf dem farbigen papier pannen sind
super weil dabei immer etwas neues
entsteht
über diese dinge habe ich nicht die
volle kontrolle
was können wir müssen über den preis
reden
ein mindestpreis liegt bei 550
wenn wir das erreichen wollen brauchen
wir eine strategie wenn wir bei 490
staaten können wir bis 550 gehen ja
glaub mir heutzutage wissen die käufer
sehr gut über den markt bescheid
sie kennen den wert der objekte und wenn
sie die qualität des objekts erkennen
wird sie das zum kommen motivieren und
so bildete dann draußen auf der straße
mit all den anderen leuten schlange
stehen werden sie die spannung spüren
sie werden sehen dass das haus super
schön ist und werden mehr bieten
ich hoffe nur dass die leute wirklich
kommen
ich sorge dafür dass sie euch die bude
ein
jetzt können wir uns verabschieden ok
meine lieben macht's gut
ich benutze sind das sales pitch
ich weiß nicht wie man das auf die zeit
dass hunderte vor riedstraße abgewertet
was ich sage ich mitmachen
ich sehe nach geschäften verkauft werden
dürfen
monika und tappara sich nicht so heiß
ist architektur immobilien das heißt
auch ganze szenerien und träume zu
verkaufen
in bester hollywood manier
[Musik]
rossi ist in seine träume versunken
seine frau ist zurück aus den ferien wir
sind oft viel zu spät dran
das kommt vor
dem chor für wenig sie
[Musik]
die frauen
das wenn man frauen so sage nicht
zufrieden
muss ich wieder vollgas an alle männer
ist immer gut
[Musik]
wie vom duft der rosen angezogen
erscheint zusammen
die veh gefolgt von ihrem neffen severin
sofort macht griffbereit mit dem zug zu
tragen ihn fast monaten im exil
zurück in der schweiz schütze mit der
familie und freunden und werden ganz
viel geburtstag
zwei wochen genau letzten ja das ist so
ich mach das jetzt normalerweise machen
dass die kinder sie werden wohl beim
abräumen helfen jetzt sind sie zu sehr
in ihr spiel vertieft
hast du hunger
ich mache mal essen in sechs bis sieben
minuten ist es fertig du wirst dein
spiel unterbrechen müssen
crestor hast du hunger
ich werde jetzt kochen ihr essen in zehn
minuten
am mittwoch dürften sie vor dem essen
immer ein wenig kämen deshalb ist es
super ruhig und wie du siehst ist es
sogar noch ruhiger wenn mein mann eddie
nicht da ist er gibt heute ein konzert
die im salón einem richtig coolen club
er spielt dort die songs seines neuen
albums
wo hast du das große messe hin getan ist
das große messer es schmeckt gut nicht
wahr ja gut
die garage ist schrecklich wir brauchen
hilfe
was musst du in der garage machen wir
müssen wohl den schrank in die garage
stellen
schön sagt aber und sagte prinz
ich weiß nicht genau wahrscheinlich noch
mit an und er eröffnet heute für gang
gang dance im februar
bist du mit g9 wir dürfen nein du darfst
ja nicht du hast recht das ist total
doof aber ihr dürft nicht mitkommen soll
ich euch die band schein europa
[Musik]
kohl nicht wahr ich finds gut
ich bin so glücklich hier zu sein ich
vermisse die schweiz nicht wirklich ich
fühle mich hier freier weil ich nicht
mal meinen eltern wohne ich kann essen
gehen wann ich will und ich richte mir
die tage möglichst so ein wie es mir
gefällt
in der schweiz war es auch umständlich
weil ich in lausanne wohne aber an der
uni genf studiere weshalb ich dauernd
hin und her reisen hier gehe ich die
ganze zeit zu fuß oder ich nehme wahr
oder den tretroller ich habe viel mehr
freiheiten
außerdem weiß ich nie was auf mich
zukommt was in einer woche geschehen
wird weiß ich nicht so genau
ich bin eine verfechterin davon im hier
und jetzt zu leben
es bringt nichts zu viel über die
vergangenheit nachzudenken oder sich zu
sehr um die zukunft zu sorgen
ich versuche so gut es geht einfach den
moment zu leben und zu schätzen was
gerade ist und mich nicht dauernd zu
fragen ob ich die schweiz vermissen
[Musik]
in der nacht sind alle katzen grau randy
braucht ein paar werkzeuge
ich trage keine waffe
ich beschütze meine kunden mit meinem
körper aber ich habe immer dieses
verfasst
dabei dass man dem angreifer notfalls
ins gesicht sprühte und ich verwende
diese elektroschockpistole wenn man sie
abfeuerte und sie die haut des
angreifers berührt wird dieser kurz
ohnmächtig wenn man angegriffen wird
muss man sie so abfeiern
aber das ist nur für den notfall
ich muss sie persönlich noch nie
einsetzen aber ich trage diese dinge
immer bei mir
[Musik]
sogar in der nacht lässt der könig der
löwen seine muskeln spielen
ich komme mindestens dreimal pro woche
ins fitness center
schon als jugendlicher habe ich viel
zeit im kraftraum verbracht weil ich in
form bleiben wollte es hilft mir aktiv
zu bleiben und mich auf die arbeit
vorzubereiten
mental fühle ich mich wie ein
20-jähriger ich habe angst vor dem
älterwerden nicht mehr alles machen zu
können was ich möchte
es gefällt mir nicht mich in gewissem
sinne alt zu fühlen
ich habe begriffen dass ich es mit 54
ein bisschen ruhiger nehmen muss
[Musik]
das atelier die kinder dann gleich
weiter ins konzert ihres mannes das
leben einer künstlerin steht nie still
[Musik]
in los angeles kreuzen sich die
schicksale
jeder hat einen lebenstraum jeder sucht
einen sinn
einige bleiben andere brechen wieder auf
für dora nimmt der kalifornische traum
ein ende
und der schweizer traum form an
[Musik]
bis später
ich bin nicht leichtfertig aber
beziehungen mit verschiedenen frauen für
mich stimmt das so es war keine ernst zu
nehmende prüfung mittendrin sagte der
prof aufgabe sechs ist unlösbar
hier sind die korrekturen bei frage 1b
epsilon gilt 525 minuten vergeblich
versucht habe die aufgabe zu lösen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe das gefühl ich bin bei meiner
eigenen beerdigung
[Musik]
heute
schwitzen in los angeles präsentiert
wurde forces stock diamond egal wo sie
sind
[Musik]